[Applause]
oh my God I just hugged Jesse and on the
second guest got his perfume or cologne
yeah it's cologne yeah yeah yeah oh my
God I love you I love the way you smell
and I'm so excited you're here today
thank you thank you guys okay Jesse the
reason that we have this batting cage
set up because we kind of thought okay
maybe just maybe that you and I could do
a little batting considering that your
Tony award-winning play congratulations
on that by the way
I mean that is the ultimate dream that's
really cool you know it's pretty cool
like to get to that kind of
acknowledgment and award-winning place
that's just so amazing and it is about
baseball
um whether it's the metaphor in the
background
um but um I was wondering if maybe while
we're talking you could sort of are you
good at baseball can you teach me let's
do it all right here we go all right
and we're gonna do some uh some hitting
yeah yeah let's do this all right you
you're gonna take the first swing and
show me how it's done and then I'm gonna
try to oh you know right
um because you also have some special
baseball experience growing up right I
grew up playing yeah yeah um me and my I
have two brothers one of them played he
was really excellent as well my dad was
our coach he's obsessed with baseball
the numbers of baseball the science of
it the story The like studying the
statistics and everything it was uh
pretty intense
um but it was a huge bonding experience
for for us and for me and it's kind of
one of the main reasons why I chose to
do the play was kind of an homage to my
father and that time together and
um so glad he enjoys it it's a sport
that kind of covers the art of Life yeah
all right definitely see what your hits
like okay so uh some basic mechanics
here it's all about like any your tennis
swing a golf swing it's your hips it's
mostly your hips and your shoulders
so your hips are what are giving you
that torque to hit the ball
um
yeah so um
like chopping a tree letting it go at
the end and letting it go not fighting
and not resisting it on the way back
it's like swinging through and it's
about rotating your hips and planting
that front foot are you also like
tensing up your core yeah with all
things you really should be locked in
your core so what's happening see my
core Jesse it's uh I've had two kids you
know so you got it my core is more like
a fish tank on a pole so it's like
Crossing around that's an incredible uh
visual
um so this carcass did make two children
that's not the right word that is not
true Tupperware man get us a strong
front foot here even maybe line it up
with the ball okay and I'll pretend that
this is your hips okay you want to
that's your rotation that's your
rotation and just let your arms your
arms go along with it all right all
right oh God here we go
I believe in you I believe in you you
got it here we go
there we go it's all right
does that count something went forward
something went down I hit something you
made an impact let's put it that way
that's uh you know the the adage is I on
the ball right you started as a teacher
and you are really teaching me right now
and being ever so kind and patient very
busy and truly well I teach when I'm
working on them teaching my kids how to
play as well how is that going it's
going great it's actually really
wonderful there we go
look at that that was amazing
that was out of here
that was out of here
oh my God
[Music]